hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse Orion comm and in this video we're
going to go over how to find veins in
the hand the hands are a popular place
to draw blood or start an IV and I'm
going to give you some tips and tricks
that I've learned over the years of
being a nurse of how to get those veins
to pop up and how to get the best IV
access so let's get started okay in the
healthcare profession we like to use the
hand veins they're easy to go to they're
usually really superficial not deep like
your AC veins or your for harm vein and
and they're typically easier to hit by
some things you want to watch out for if
this patient you're getting is going to
be good in getting like vesicant drugs
meaning these are drugs hard on the hand
like vinegar in some antibiotics
amiodarone you would never never use a
hand bang because these veins are
fragile you would want to use a large
vein or the patient would need a central
line so make sure you see what all the
word for your patient also is your
patient there for a possible pulmonary
embolism so they're probably going to be
going for a CT with P protocol and you
would have to get an 18-gauge and their
AC so you wouldn't even need to bother
using the hand and you need to ask
yourself is your patient going to be you
getting a lot of drugs a lot of drips
probably won't use a hand veins let's
use bigger vein but I'm also ask the
patient a lot of patients do not like
veins and IVs in their hand because it
hurts and it is a sensitive area so just
warn the patient because there's a lot
of nerves there so what I like to do is
I like to begin by putting the
tourniquet on some people put the
tourniquet above the elbow but whenever
I'm doing the hand I put the tourniquet
about right here in this area so let's
do that and if you don't know how to
properly put on a tourniquet I have a
video on how to put a tourniquet on
properly because there's a way you want
to do it okay
it's on and what you're going to do is
you're going to have the patient pump
their hand because that's going to cause
all this blood to pull into these veins
and engorge them and make them really
large because you're going to decrease
your chances of missing this vein if
this vein is popping up at you that's a
lot of issues
new beginners have they don't get that
vain nicely and engorge okay so you can
quit pumping your hand and just look at
how beautiful these veins are they've
just really popped up there
now if you have a patient who's
dehydrated you definitely want to get
this done with the tourniquet on fairly
tight having them pump if you have
someone who has really cold hands who
have bad circulation try to get a warm
blanket and put that over their hands to
make those veins come more to the
surface because you in order to get the
veins of the hand you have to have them
close to the skin now let's zoom in and
look at these veins
okay these veins are nice and engorge
another technique if you're having
problems getting these veins and gorge
have the patient dangle their arm down
by their side so all this blood just
pulls down there and another thing you
can do to get these veins to really slap
out or pop out at you is you can sort of
slapping like this I don't know if
you've ever seen someone doing that but
it just causes them to really just
bounce up and just become a little bit
more visible and this one popped up a
little bit more and it just allows you
to be able to see it a little bit better
okay
now what we want to do I'm going to show
you the importance on picking a right
good vein in the hand what you're going
to look for whenever you are especially
starting an IV you want something that
is straight you don't want something
that's curved or really small like this
because look this is a 22-gauge IV
doesn't have a needle this is the
cannula and this part is what is going
to go in the vein of the patient so you
want a nice vein that's straight because
if not you're going to risk the chances
of going through the vein you're going
to blow the vein or something like that
so what we'd want to pick for this is
this vein is really nice looking right
here and you would not want to use this
vein right here that is way too small
that's a great vein for drawing blood
but not a good vein for sticking a
cannula in see it's not long enough so
you want to use this one or that one
right there now one thing that you have
to watch out for see where these two
veins have branched out into one is
bifurcated right there there's a valve
in there somewhere and a lot of times
whenever you're poking
the ivy with a needle you'll hit it and
you're not going to get blood returned
it's like oh no am I not in the vein but
what's happened is that you've hit this
valve and you're just not getting a
blood return so if you try to thread it
in and flush it you're probably going to
see that it's in there but just be aware
of that you probably hit a valve and
that's where those valves are is
whenever these little veins like to
bifurcate now after you do that after
you decide what type of vein you want
you want to make sure that you don't
have a rolling vein everyone's heard of
the dreaded rolling mates
and your hands like to roll because
they're super superficial but after
years of technique I have learned how to
prevent that okay what you want to do is
you just want to look and see how these
veins roll move the skin around look
touch on it see how whenever I touch it
just with my finger it like moves to the
side yeah that's called rolling now if I
had if I went in with a needle right now
with his hand relaxed like this it's
just going to go to the side and I want
to miss it
and I'm going to get frustrated so what
you need to do to prevent that have the
patient make a fist okay and tell them
not a tight fist but a light fist just
like that because if they make too tired
of a RIF this it's going to make these
veins flat and you don't want that so a
light wrist this and you're going to
poke the needle in and it's just and you
can hold right here above it and just
keep your veins stabilized so you notice
how whenever I'm touching with my finger
that Magna just stayin in place and it's
not rolling like how it was earlier that
is just an awesome way to prevent that
from happening so anytime you're doing
this hold it have the patient make a
fist and go straight in and you're going
to get it every time so that is how you
find a vein in the hand hands are easy
typically people have great veins in the
hand just try to use these techniques
that I showed you and you should
increase your success rate in getting an
IV or drawing blood out of hand bangs
okay that is how you find veins in the
hand I hope this helps you out be sure
to check out my other videos on how to
start an IV the difference between
different IV gauge needles and things
like that and thank you so much for
watching and be sure to subscribe to my
You Tube channel